too hot to handle ist so ca das
bekannteste Netflix reality TV Format in
dem extrem heiße Singles auf eine
unbekannte tropische Insel geschickt
werden und alles machen dürfen außer
Liebe
davon wissen die Teilnehmer und
Teilnehmerinnen allerdings gar nichts
von Netflix dachte sich jetzt Mensch
dass ich reingehauen das hat
auch stimmt auf italienisch
und jetzt
Deutschland endet und da darf ich euch
heute recht herzlich willkommen heißen
bei 2 hot to handle Germany hallo im
heißesten Paradies Seite Singles gibt
willkommen
und Sex geht das perfekte
Täuschungsmanöver aber
sorry dass der ganz kurz interveniere
keiner der TeilnehmerInnen kennt
wahrscheinlich dieses Wort aber ganz
dumm gesprochen
es muss in einem Vertrag
genauestens drin stehen auf was du dich
dort ein lässt also entweder wussten die
Teilnehmer Teilnehmerinnen das wirklich
vorher und spielen jetzt einfach oder
die haben den Vertrag nicht richtig
gelesen weil wenn dort nicht in
irgendeiner Klausel juristisch head hat
irgendwie drin steht das könnt ihr auch
eine andere Schau Handeln könntest du
Netflix auf Millionen verklagen
also das verstehe ich da immer nicht so
ganz weil wir schauen uns den Lachs mal
an
aktiv datensammelmodus
was in diesem Ressort passiert von Lana
unbeobachtet bleiben
ich will auch in Urlaub
[Musik]
warum drehen die Natur zu Ende Germany
trotzdem dann auf irgendeiner tropischen
Insel warum nimmt er nicht Frankfurter
Hauptbahnhof das passt viel mehr zu
Deutschland und da kommt auch schon
unsere erste nichts an Göttin
oh mein Gott bin ich blöd oder
[Musik]
kennt man die nicht von tickt kennen sie
nur weil sie irgendwie Videos mit ihrer
Oma glaube ich gemacht hat oder ich
versuche mich gerade dass sie jetzt bei
Torte mit macht kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen und da steht auch Ibiza sie
kommt auch nicht mal aus Deutschland es
ist genauso Sinn befreit wie wenn bei
GNTM dann unten steht kommt aus
Österreich nein Bro das ist Germany's
next Topmodel nicht Austria Sex next
Topmodel
[Musik]
mich einfach absolut langweilig wird
mal ganz kurz
schreib mir mal bitte in die Kommentare
ob ihr so etwas aufnehmen könntet
verlaufender Kamera
also ich denke ja dass ich mich schon
oft zum Affen mache hier ne aber das ist
ja
[Musik]
Dennis
aus Berlin
natürlich danke ich habe mich gerade
schon gefragt wie viel Uhr gerade ich
bin's geil
oh mein Gott ich kann wirklich
ich könnte meine eigenen Scheiße gerade
ertrinken das ist ja so Grinch was
machst du beruflich bin Make-up Artist
ja gleich mal zusammen tun
oh mein Gott
das ist so eine richtige
kennenlernunterhaltung in der Shisha Bar
ne
komplett
[Musik]
London Barcelona okay kommen wir mal
beim nächsten Mal
oh mein Gott ey es ist also die erste
Folge hätte ich dir eins zu eins
Skripten können ne kommen die Leute und
egal wer ist einfach ausrasten oh mein
Gott leck mich am Arsch wer seid ihr
denn bin ich leicht überfordert ich
brauche jetzt mal so ein bisschen so
kein Wingman hier an meiner Seite okay
mein Gott klar
ich kann nicht mehr
richtig
oder diese Emily heißt ja glaube ich
diese Emily will auf jeden Fall mein
Charakter sein
das merkt man direkt die will die ganze
Zeit reden die ganze Zeit dass es sich
um sich dreht die dann die spielt mit
der Kamera die ganze Zeit in die Haare
und blablablabla das finde ich extrem
anstrengend aber wir schauen mal wie es
sich entwickelt das ist jetzt die erste
Folge die dort rausgekommen ist kein
Kopf akzeptieren kann
[Musik]
ich kann eigentlich finde mir meine neue
Uhr kann sogar hier die Uhrzeit anzeigen
ich bin Model und Fußballer von Beruf
Fußballer
denn im Moment
Partys Frau und Monat stands
so das ist mein Weib warte mal kurz also
stabiler Blick Kevin
Kevin
yeah stimmt
Regionalliga Nord Brot hab ich höher
gespielt
immer positiv war
also
nee ich erlaubt mir jetzt erstmal noch
keinen Urteil
ich stehe auf Augen also seid gerade
guter Spruch
Leute august in dem Glas der Spruch ist
gut Laura aus Berlin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
war doch wieder so klar Alter ey das ist
doch alles einfach immer das gleiche
ist das Mike singer
und Sami Khedira oder Emre Ciao wieder
linke sind Fabian Acker aus Wien ich
kann doch ab
Germany gehört Österreich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr gut wie macht man das mit diesem
küssen
ich bin immer überfordert wenn eine Frau
oder meistens sind ja wenn ich Freunde
von meinen Eltern treffe ältere Damen
wenn die anderen so auf Clash diese
begrüßen wollen bin ich mal leicht
überfordert man macht jetzt erst links
und rechts
macht man zwei oder macht man drei weil
manchmal machen Leute
keine Ahnung kussi
es kommt sehr gut mit Frauen an aber
eigentlich bin ich Türke
also
er ist Türke
wohnt in Wien und macht bei Twitter
Germany mit
also entweder hat Netflix sich da nicht
richtig informiert oder die haben in
Deutschland nicht genügend Models
gefunden ich weiß ja gar nicht warum die
nur Models nehmen ich hatte da echt no
joke einige influencer erwartet und wir
haben ja in Deutschland wirklich viele
Influenza die direkt in so eine Schiene
gehen würden extrem stark im Bett ich
auch
ich kann no joke 11 Stunden locker am
Stück durch pennen was machst du
beruflich ich bin Model und du sam sam
alter das ist doch
was machst du beruflich
Models ab klar bei mir zieht's ey was
seid ihr für
testosterongesteuerte Individuen oh mein
Gott
oh mein Gott
oh mein Gott jeder steht auf dine
ey was mich halt also ich finde sie vom
äußerlichen ist sie auf jeden Fall ein
hübsches Mädchen auf jeden Fall aber was
mich direkt nerven würde und wo ich
direkt sagen würde nein auf gar keinen
Fall weil ich habe das ja auch schon
Podcast häufig gesagt bei mir ist es
auch so wenn ich nur on als standmäßig
unterwegs bin oder nur kurz was mit dem
Mädel habe oder so spielen bei mir
trotzdem innere Werte immer mit auch
beim ersten Mal auch wenn man nur einmal
was haben möchte spielt immer mit und
ich finde wenn sie so von der Art der so
sau extrovertiert ist die ganze Zeit oh
mein Gott Kennedy dead du dieses
englische international
das schöne Menschen dumm sind aber ich
bin eigentlich der lebende Beweis dass
es nicht so ist
okay wenn man sowas behauptet dann muss
man auf jeden Fall auch Taten sprechen
lassen ich kann aus meinen Erfahrungen
der letzten Monate auf jeden Fall
sprechen dass je hübscher ein Mädchen
war mit der ich was hatte sie wirklich
emotional gesehen nicht so am Start war
weil und da habe ich mit ein paar Kumpel
sie Theorie aufgestellt wir glauben dass
egal ob wie gesagt auf Typen kann ich
nicht beziehen ich bin heterosexuelle
Frauen aber bei Mädels haben wir es auf
jeden Fall so beobachtet dass hübsche
Mädels wahrscheinlich weniger innere
Werte Beziehungen aufbauen weil sie
schon über diese äußerliche Schiene so
am bängen sind sage ich mal in der
Gesellschaft deswegen
baut sich dieses innere gar nicht auf
dieses Verständnis dafür und dass sie da
überhaupt sich einen Charakter richtig
selber aufbaut wisst ihr wie ich meine
Mädels die jetzt äußerlich gesprochen
vielleicht nicht so diesem Haupt Ideal
von irgendeinem Typen entsprechen
wiederum haben einen super geilen
Charakter und es ist ganz ganz schwer
eine ge ile Mischung zu finden aus
beidem wollen Mädchen wirklich beides
mitbringt
ist es die Therapiestunde mit Luca ist
Technik eigentlich der Mittelpunkt mir
ist es wichtig dass alles verbunden ist
dass ich einfach zu meiner Alexa sagt
okay macht es nicht dann mach die Musik
an das ist immerhin mal eine Frau die
ohne wenn du aber auch nicht hörst finde
ich ist das schlimmste was es gibt also
Alexa gute Idee blablab wir brauchen gar
nichts gegen sagen funktioniert auch
krass aber ich ich will normalen
Lichtschalter ich will den drücken Licht
geht an ich drücke dir noch mal Licht
aus ich will dich jetzt immer klatschen
sage Alexa mache sondern dreht sich mein
Haus zum Kreis meistens habe Frauen
zuzugehen weil sie dann von vorne stehen
oh mein Gott
ich kann das nicht mehr
ich kann es nicht mehr
[Musik]